le ciné parc saint eustache est un
rendez-vous visiblement populaire une
fois à l'intérieur petits et grands se
met à l'aise pour votre film en plein
air si fanni a apporté ses réserves des
types l1 après dont 26 en avait en plus
est chez moi j'en ai envie réd un autre
écran des cinéphiles sont là pour la
bière finalement c'est l'occasion pour
faire la partie
moi j'ai réussi pour les inventer aux
états unis en 1933
les premiers ciné parc au québec sont
apparus dans les années 1970 délaissée
pendant un long moment
il y à un regain d'intérêt inchangés
depuis quelques années du roi lion
l'année passée et que c'est un phénomène
c'était quasiment dans un écrasement
belles voitures à tous les oies pendant
les deux semaines de vacances de
construction fait que c'est un phénomène
que les gens ont recommencé à vivre
sympa il ya pour l'instant 5 ciné-parc
au québec mais leur nombre va augmenter
dès le mois de juillet la ville de
québec va en ouvrir deux et possiblement
un troisième dont l'accès sera gratuit
et à montréal
le nouveau théâtre ciné parcs royaux
menthe ouvrira ses portes dimanche et il
pourra accueillir jusqu'à 250 automobile
on a créé un concept de 1,6 n'est pas
requis et pas juste pour les films mais
un ciné parc qui fournit une salle de
spectacles pour tout genre d'événement
en ville sont on va voir des artistes et
musiciens des comédiens à des cérémonies
de graduation pour attirer un nouveau
public
le ciné parc orford a fait appel à
montmagny factory soit un son et lumière
le belz on va passer par la radio fm
mais il va voir vraiment un jeu de
lumière
dans le à l'entrée du site à la sortie
du site
autant de la pandémie le ciné parc est
une valeur refuge
on fait même la file sur l'autoroute
pour aller au ciné parc saint eustache
le film lytro deux ans chante la jeune
tiffany
on sait qu'on l'attend même des
oreillers petite couche en train
d'écouter le funky et qui joue là on a
envie d'en mais c'est à moi qu'on est
venus ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
saint-eustache